Les encantará saber que no hablaré de mi propia tragedia,
sino de la de otros.
Es más fácil tomar a la ligera la tragedia de otros que la propia
y lo haré para mantener el ánimo de la conferencia.
Entonces si creen en los relatos de los medios,
ser traficante en la cima de la epidemia de crack
era una vida glamorosa, en palabras de Virginia Postrel,
tenías dinero, drogas, armas, mujeres,
lo que quisieran... joyas, bling-bling... de todo.
Les voy a contar de una investigación de 10 años,
de una oportunidad única de entrar a una banda,
de ver sus libros, los registros financieros reales de la banda,
que pertenecer a una banda no es una vida glamorosa.
Creo, siendo más realistas, que pertenecer a una banda
y vender drogas es quizá el peor trabajo en todo los Estados Unidos.
Y hoy los quiero convencer de eso.
Así que quiero hacer tres cosas.
Primero, explicar cómo y por qué el crack
tuvo tan profunda influencia en las bandas urbanas.
Segundo, contarles cómo alguien como yo
pudo ver el funcionamiento interno de una banda.
Una historia interesante, creo yo,
y tercero, quiero contarles, someramente
algunas cosas que descubrimos cuando vimos realmente
los registros financieros, los libros de la banda.
Antes de eso, una advertencia:
esta presentación fue calificada como no apta para menores,
contiene temas para adultos, lenguaje para mayores.
Dado que yo daré la charla, les dará gusto saber
que no contiene desnudez,
salvo que…
(Risas)
hubiese un inesperado desperfecto de vestuario.
Comencemos hablando del crack y cómo transformó las bandas.
Para eso debemos remontarnos al tiempo anterior al crack
a inicios de los 80 y véanlo desde la perspectiva de un líder de banda.
A mediados de los 80, ser líder de una banda no era un mal negocio,
inicios de los 80, digamos.
Tenías, poder, mandabas a golpear gente,
tenías prestigio, respeto...
Pero no había dinero ¿de acuerdo?
La banda no tenía manera de ganar dinero
y no podían cobrar a la gente en la banda
porque ellos tampoco tenían dinero.
No se ganaba vendiendo marihuana.
La marihuana resulta ser demasiado barata,
nadie se enriquece vendiendo marihuana.
No podían vender cocaína
que es un gran producto
pero tienes que conocer gente blanca y rica.
Y los miembros de las bandas urbanas no conocían gente blanca y rica,
no podían vender a ese mercado.
Tampoco podían cometer delitos menores,
que es una forma terrible de ganarse la vida.
Como resultado siendo líder de banda tenías, sí, poder,
una buena vida.
Pero al final del día, terminabas viviendo en casa de tu madre.
Así que no era una carrera
Tenía límites a cuán poderoso e importante podías ser,
si tenías que vivir con tu madre.
Entonces llegó el crack.
En palabras de Malcolm Gladwell, el crack fue la versión
extra-sabrosa de la salsa de tomate.
(Risas)
Porque el crack fue una innovación increíble
Hoy no me da tiempo de hablar al respecto.
Pero si lo piensan, diría que en los últimos 25 años
de todos los inventos o innovaciones en este país,
el más grande por su impacto en el bienestar de la gente
que vive en las ciudades, fue el crack,
para mal, no para bien, para peor.
Tuvo un enorme impacto en la vida.
¿Pero qué tenía el crack?
Era una manera brillante de estimular el cerebro,
porque el crack lo puedes fumar y la cocaína en polvo, no
y fumar es un mecanismo más eficiente para drogarse
que aspirar.
Entonces había este público que no sabía que quería crack
pero que cuando llegó, se dio cuenta
que era la droga perfecta. Podías venderla por…
comprar cocaína que costaba un dólar y venderla en cinco dólares.
Altamente adictiva, el estímulo era muy breve.
Durante quince minutos estabas drogado.
Luego, cuando terminaba, lo único que querías era hacerlo otra vez.
Creó un mercado maravilloso
y para quienes dirigían la banda
parecía una buena forma, en apariencia, de hacer mucho dinero;
al menos para aquellos en la cima.
Entonces es cuando entramos a escena.
No yo, en realidad mi papel es secundario.
Mi coautor, Sudhir Venkatesh, es el protagonista.
Graduado de matemáticas con un gran corazón
y decidido a obtener un doctorado en sociología,
vino a la Universidad de Chicago.
Tres meses antes de llegar a Chicago se la había pasado
siguiendo a "The Grateful Dead."
Y, en sus propias palabras, "se veía como un tipo raro".
Un surasiático de piel muy oscura,
un hombre grande y con pelo largo hasta "el culo".
Desafiaba cualquier clasificación, ¿blanco o negro? ¿Hombre o mujer?
Verlo era realmente una visión curiosa.
Se presentó en la Universidad de Chicago
y el famoso sociólogo, William Julius Wilson,
estaba escribiendo un libro y necesitaba hacer encuestas en todo Chicago.
Miró a Sudhir, quien iba a hacer algunas encuestas para él
y supo exactamente el lugar a dónde iba a enviarlo,
al más peligroso y notorio de los proyectos de urbanización,
no sólo en Chicago, sino de todo Estados Unidos.
Entonces Sudhir, muchacho de la afueras que nunca había estado dentro de la ciudad
muy obediente tomó su tabla y se encaminó hacia ese proyecto urbano.
Llega al primer edificio.
¿En el primer edificio? No hay nadie.
Pero oye voces en la escalera,
así que sube y al doblar la esquina,
se encuentra un grupo de afroamericanos jugando a los dados.
Esto fue como en los 90, en la cima de la epidemia de crack.
Pertenecer a una banda es un trabajo peligroso, no quieres ser sorprendido,
no te gusta ser sorprendido por gente doblando la esquina.
La regla era: dispara primero, pregunta después.
Sudhir tuvo suerte.
Era un tipo tan raro
y quizá la tabla le salvó la vida, pues pensaron
que ninguna banda rival vendría a matarlos con una tabla.
(Risas)
Su bienvenida no fue especialmente cálida pero le dijeron
bueno, OK, oigamos tus preguntas.
Y, no les miento, la primera pregunta en la encuesta que le encomendaron era,
"¿Cómo se siente ser pobre y negro en Estados Unidos?"
(Risas)
Da qué pensar de los académicos ¿no?
Y las opciones eran: Muy Bien, Bien, Mal y Muy Mal.
Sudhir descubrió que la verdadera respuesta era la siguiente...
[Véte a la mierda] (Risas)
La encuesta no fue, al final lo que salvó a Sudhir.
Lo mantuvieron rehén toda la noche en esa escalera.
Hubo muchos tiroteos,
muchas discusiones filosóficas con miembros de la banda.
A la mañana, llegó el líder de la banda,
revisó a Sudhir,
decidió que no era una amenaza y lo dejó ir.
Sudhir se fue a casa, se duchó y tomó una siesta.
Ustedes y yo ante esta situación pensaríamos
bueno, creo que voy a escribir mi disertación sobre "The Grateful Dead",
pues ya los estuve siguiendo por tres meses.
(Risas)
Sudhir, por otro lado, volvió al proyecto de urbanización.
Subió al segundo piso y dijo,
" Amigos, me divertí tanto con ustedes anoche,
que me preguntaba si podía quedarme otra vez".
Y ese fue el comienzo de una hermosa relación
en la que por 10 años Sudhir vivió yendo y viniendo al proyecto
yendo a casas de crack, a prisión con miembros de la banda,
recibiendo disparos en las ventanas de su auto
la policía entrando a su apartamento a robar los discos de su computadora,
lo que se les ocurra.
Pero la historia tuvo un final feliz para Sudhir,
quien se convirtió en uno de los sociólogos más respetados del país.
Y para mí, que estaba sentado en mi oficina con mi planilla de Excel abierta,
esperando que Sudhir volviera y me entregara los datos más recientes
que había conseguido de la banda.
Fue una de las relaciones de coautoría más desiguales que ha habido
(Risas)
pero me congratulo de ser el beneficiario.
¿Qué descubrimos en la banda? Les diré una cosa.
Realmente tuvimos acceso a todos en la banda,
conocimos a la banda por dentro desde bajo hasta arriba
Confiaron en Sudhir de una manera en que ningún académico
o nadie ajeno a ellos ha ganado el respeto de estas bandas,
al punto en que abrieron lo que más me interesaba:
sus libros, sus registros contables.
Los tuvimos disponibles para nosotros
y no sólo pudimos estudiarlos, sino que pudimos hacer preguntas sobre los mismos.
Si tuviera que resumir en el poco tiempo que tengo
la esencia de lo que obtuvimos de la banda es
que si tuviera que trazar un paralelo entre la banda y cualquier otra organización
sería que la banda es igual a McDonald's.
En muchos aspectos es como el restaurante McDonald's
Primero, en un aspecto, quizá no el más interesante
pero es buen comienzo, es la manera de organizarse.
La jerarquía de la banda, la manera como se ve.
Este es el organigrama de la banda.
No sé si conocen acerca de organigramas,
pero si tuvieran que simplificar el organigrama de McDonald's
así es como se vería.
Es asombroso, pero el nivel superior de la banda
se llama a sí mismo la "junta de directores".
(Risas)
Y Sudhir dice que no es porque tengan una visión sofisticada
de las corporaciones estadounidenses,
sino porque han visto películas como "Wall Street" y como que aprendieron
un poco sobre cómo es estar en ese mundo.
Debajo de la junta de directores tenemos esencialmente VP regionales
gente que controla, digamos, el sur de Chicago, o el oeste.
Sudhir llegó a conocer al sujeto con la desafortunada tarea
de tratar de dirigir la franquicia de Iowa.
(Risas)
Que, para esta banda negra, no fue una de las más brillantes
operaciones financieras que hayan emprendido.
(Risas)
Pero lo que realmente hace que la banda parezca McDonald's son las franquicias.
Los sujetos que dirigen las bandas locales
las áreas de cuatro por cuatro cuadras
son igual a los sujetos, que dirigen un McDonald's.
Ellos son los emprendedores,
tienen los derechos exclusivos de controlar la venta de drogas,
mantienen el nombre de la banda para la comercialización y el mercadeo
y son los que básicamente hacen o pierden las ganancias
dependiendo de cómo dirigen el negocio.
El grupo en el que quiero que piensen, son los están hasta abajo
los soldados rasos.
Típicamente son adolescentes
parados en una esquina vendiendo las drogas,
un trabajo en extremo peligroso.
Y es importante notar que casi todo el peso, toda la gente
en esta organización están abajo,
igual que en McDonald's
En cierto sentido, el soldado raso se parece a
quien toma órdenes en McDonald's
y no es casualidad que se parezcan.
De hecho, en estos vecindarios, son las mismas personas,
los mismos chicos que trabajan en la banda están también
al mismo tiempo, trabajando medio tiempo
en un lugar como McDonald's.
Lo cual prefigura la conclusión de lo que estoy contando
acerca de cuán malo es el trabajo de estar en una banda.
Porque obviamente, si estar en una banda fuera un trabajo lucrativo
¿por qué en el cielo estos chicos además trabajan en McDonalds?
¿Cómo es la paga? Se sorprenderían.
Pero basados en los hechos...
pudiendo hablar con ellos y ver sus registros
así es como se ve en términos de salarios.
La paga de los soldados rasos era 3.50 dólares la hora,
por debajo del salario mínimo y esto está documentado.
Es fácil ver, por los patrones de consumo que tienen.
Esto no es ficción, es un hecho
Había muy poco dinero en la banda especialmente en el rango bajo.
Si alcanzan a subir, digamos, hasta líder local,
el equivalente al dueño de una franquicia de McDonalds
ganarían 100 000 dólares al año.
En cierta forma, es el mejor trabajo al que pueden aspirar,
si crecieron en uno de estos vecindarios como joven negro.
Si alcanzan a subir a la cima
200 000 o 400000 dólares al año es lo que podrían ganar.
Ciertamente la suya sería una historia de éxito.
Pero uno de los aspectos tristes de esto es que, entre otras ramificaciones del crack,
es que los individuos más talentosos
en estas comunidades aspiran a esto.
No tratan de lograrlo de manera legítimas
porque no hay opciones legítimas.
Ésta era la mejor opción
y realmente era la opción correcta, probablemente para lograrlo de esta manera.
Miren esto.
La relación con McDonald's termina aquí
El dinero es parecido.
¿Por qué es tan mal trabajo?
La razón por la que es tan mal trabajo es que habrá alguien
que te estará disparando a cada rato.
Habiendo tiroteos ¿cuáles son las tasas de mortalidad?
En nuestra banda y, admitimos, que esta
no es una situación estándar,
era un momento de intensa violencia --de guerras de bandas--
y esta banda llegó a ser bastante exitosa, pero hubo costos.
Y el índice, sin mencionar el índice de arrestos,
condenas penales, heridos, el índice de mortalidad en nuestra muestra
fue del 7% por persona por año.
Estando en la banda 4 años tenías un 25% de probabilidades de morir.
Esto es lo más alto que puedes alcanzar.
Para fines comparativos, pensemos en otra situación
que uno espera sea extremadamente riesgosa.
Digamos que eres un asesino,
encarcelado por asesinato y condenado a pena de muerte.
Resulta que los índices de mortalidad de los condenados a muerte
por cualquier causa, incluyendo la ejecución es de 2% anual.
(Risas)
Es mucho más seguro estar condenado a muerte que vender droga en la calle.
Esto te hace pensar en aquellos que creen
que la pena de muerte va a tener un efecto disuasivo en el crimen.
Para darles una idea de lo malo que era la ciudad en el tiempo del crack
y no me estoy concentrando en lo negativo,
pero allí hay otra historia que contar,
si miran las tasas de mortalidad
al azar, de jóvenes negros en grandes urbes de Estados Unidos,
los índices durante el crack eran cerca del 1%.
Eso es extremadamente alto.
Y esto es por muerte violenta; en cierto sentido, inverosímil.
Para ponerlo en perspectiva, si lo comparas con los soldados en Irak
por ejemplo, estacionados en la guerra: 0.5 por ciento.
En una forma muy literal, los jóvenes negros creciendo
en este país están viviendo en una zona de guerra, en el mismo sentido
en que los soldados en Irak están peleando una guerra.
¿Por qué, se preguntarán, alguien estaría dispuesto a vender
drogas en una esquina por 3.50 la hora, sabiendo que tiene
un 25% de probabilidad de morir en los próximos 4 años?
¿Por qué lo harían? Creo que hay un par de respuestas.
Creo que la primera es que fueron engañados por la historia.
La banda solía ser un rito de transición.
Que la gente joven controlaba la banda y cuando envejecías,
salías de la banda.
Lo que sucedió fue que
quienes estuvieron a la hora correcta en el lugar correcto,
quienes dirigieron la banda a mediados de los 80,
se hizo muy, muy rica.
Y lo más lógico de pensar era que: "La próxima generación
va a reemplazar la banda como sucede con todos
y la próxima generación va a llegar y apropiarse de la riqueza".
Hay sorprendentes similitudes, creo, con el boom de la Internet.
Los primeros en Silicon Valley se hicieron muy, muy ricos
y todos mis amigos dijeron: "Yo debería hacer eso también".
Aceptaron trabajar con poco salario a cambio de acciones que nunca redituaron.
En cierto sentido, eso es lo que sucedió a esta gente
que analizamos, estaban dispuestos a comenzar desde abajo.
Al igual que un abogado en un bufete legal
dispuesto a comenzar en su primer año desde abajo,
trabajando 80 horas por semana por poco dinero,
porque cree que lo harán socio;
pero después las reglas cambian y nunca lo hacen socio.
Las mismas personas que controlaban las bandas a fines de los 80
todavía hoy controlan las principales bandas en Chicago,
nunca pasaron la riqueza.
Todos se quedaron atascados con un trabajo de 3.50 la hora y fue un desastre.
La otra cosa fue que las bandas fueron muy buenas en comercializar.
Por ejemplo, algo que la banda hacía
es que los líderes tenían grandes recorridos,
y conducían autos lujosos y tenían joyas caras.
Sudhir se dio cuenta, a medida que pasaba tiempo con ellos
de que en realidad no eran dueños de esos autos.
Los alquilaban porque no podían pagar un auto caro
Y su joyería no era de oro sino de chapa de oro.
Volvemos a lo real-real versus lo falso-real.
Y en verdad hicieron muchas cosas para engañar a los jóvenes
para convencerlos de que era buen negocio estar en la banda.
Por ejemplo, a un chico de 14 años le daban
un fajo de billetes para que lo guardara.
El chico de 14 años diría: "Bien…"
Le diría entonces a sus amigos:
"Miren el dinero que conseguí en la banda".
No era su dinero, hasta que se lo gastaba. Y entonces esencialmente estaba
en deuda con la banda y era un empleado endeudado.
Me queda un par de minutos.
Haré una última cosa
que no pensé que tendría tiempo, que es hablar de lo que aprendimos,
en general, sobre la economía del estudio de la banda.
Los economistas tienden a hablar con palabras técnicas,
a menudo las teorías fallan miserablemente al recolectar datos.
Pero lo que es interesante es que en este contexto
algunas teorías que no funcionaron bien
en la economía real, funcionaron en la economía de drogas,
en cierta forma porque es capitalismo sin restricciones.
Aquí hay un principio económico,
una idea básica de economía laboral es el "diferencial de compensación".
Básicamente es el incremento de paga que requiere un trabajador
para sentirse indiferente entre realizar dos tareas
una de las cuales es más desagradable que la otra;
a eso se le llama diferencial de compensación
Por eso pensamos que quienes recogen basura
ganan más que quienes limpian parques ¿cierto?
En palabras de un miembro de la banda esto está claro
Me estoy adelantando, pero resulta
que en la banda, cuando hay guerra,
a los soldados rasos se les paga el doble.
Es exactamente este concepto,
porque no quieren arriesgarse.
Y las palabras del miembro de la banda lo expresan bien.
Dice: "¿Te quedas aquí cuando toda esta mierda... los disparos,
estén pasando? No, ¿cierto?
Si vas a pedirme que ponga mi vida al frente, hombre, el efectivo por delante".
En esencia, creo que el miembro de la banda expresa lo que está pasando
más articuladamente que el economista.
(Risas)
Otra más.
Los economistas hablan de la teoría de juegos,
que en cada juego entre dos personas hay un Equilibrio de Nash.
He aquí la traducción del miembro de la banda.
Hablando acerca de la decisión del porqué no hacen tiroteos,
algo que es una gran táctica de negocios en la banda,
si vas y disparas al aire en el territorio de otra banda
todos tendrán miedo de comprar drogas allí
y vendrán a tu vecindario.
Pero he aquí el porqué no hacen eso:
"Si comenzamos a disparar por ahí, en el territorio de la otra banda,
nadie, entiendes, nadie va a pasar por su territorio.
Pero hay que tener cuidado,
porque pueden disparar por aquí también y entonces nos jodemos todos".
(Risas)
Es exactamente el mismo concepto,
pero a veces, los economistas lo entienden mal.
Una cosa que observamos en los datos es que se ven como...
El líder de la banda siempre cobra ¿cierto?
Sin importar qué tan mal esté la economía, siempre se paga a sí mismo.
Tenemos algunas teorías acerca del flujo de efectivo
y la falta de acceso al mercado de capitales, y cosas así
Pero cuando le preguntamos al miembro de la banda
"¿Por qué siempre recibes paga y tus trabajadores no siempre cobran?"
Responde: "Tienes estos negros debajo que quieren tu trabajo ¿entiendes?
Si empiezas a tener pérdidas, entonces para ellos eres débil y mierda".
Y pensé en eso, y me dije
"Los altos ejecutivos se pagan a sí mismos bonos millonarios
incluso cuando las compañías pierden dinero;
y nunca se le ocurió a un economista que esta idea de 'débil y mierda'
podría ser en verdad importante".
Pero tal vez esto de "débil y mierda"
tal vez sea una hipótesis importante que necesita más análisis.
Muchas gracias.